what's a system of equations well
basically you know it's two equations
okay that represent lines okay generally
and we're looking for where they cross
the point of intersection now one way to
solve these really quickly on the test
is if they give you the points of
intersection you can just go ahead and
plug in those points so for example if
one of the possibilities the
multiple-choice answers was like
negative 1/2 you could say well I'm
gonna put negative 1 in for X I'm gonna
put 2 in for Y if that makes that
equation true and if I put it negative 1
in for X here and 2 and for Y and that
makes the second equation true if it
makes both the equations true we know
that's the common point of intersection
and that's our answer so you can back
substitute and that can be a very quick
and efficient way to do these types of
problems but sometimes that's not an
option so let me show you another way to
solve these problems so the first way
we're going to talk about it's the
substitution method so here what you
have is since y equals 2x plus 1 let's
go ahead and substitute or put that in
place of Y in the second equation this
way we'll get everything in terms of
just one variable X so let's go ahead
and do that so we've got 3x minus 2
instead of why I'm putting what y equals
which is 2x plus 1 equals negative 6 now
I'm going to distribute the negative 2
so that gives us 3x minus 4x minus 2
equals negative 6 combine like terms
that's negative 6 minus 2 equals
negative 6 add 2 to both sides multiply
by negative 1 or divide by negative 1
and you can see that x equals 4 now if
we want to find out what Y is we can
take X put it back into this equation or
this equation either one you'll get the
same answer I'm going to go ahead and
put it back in for X right here so
that's going to be 2 times 4 is 8 plus 1
is 9 so our answer is going to be 4
comma 9 now again if this was given as
one of the solutions you could go ahead
and back substitute to see if it makes
both equations true and you can verify
that that is the correct answer so
that's called the substitution method
the other method is called the
elimination method and what you do here
is you try to add the equations together
in such a manner that either the X's
cancel out or the Y's cancel out right
so for this one what I'm going to do is
I'm going to multiply everything in this
second equation by negative
so that this will be negative 2x when I
add it to positive 2x the x's are gonna
cancel one another out okay so you're
with me so far
so let's go ahead and multiply
everything here by negative two that
gives us negative 2x minus 2y equals
negative 14 I'm just going to bring that
top equation down below it okay like so
and if we go ahead and add these
together now you can see the X's are
cancelling one another out and we get
negative 5y equals negative 25 divide
everything by negative 5 and you can see
that y equals 5 now all we have to do is
take that 5 put it back in for y into
either one of these equations I'm going
to put it here because it's gonna be a
little bit easier and we've got X plus 5
equals 7 subtract 5 from both sides and
you can see that x equals 2 so our final
answer is going to be the cop the
coordinate 2 comma 5
now sometimes on the SAT it'll say you
know solve for X plus y and in which
case you would just add these together
you would say 2 plus 5 is 7 and that's
your answer or it'll just say what's the
the y-coordinate and you would just list
you know the Y value you don't have to
list both points so pay attention to the
format they give it to you in but
basically you can use a substitution
elimination or the back substitution
method to solve these systems of
equations so now here's your turn to get
some practice let's do these two
problems here go ahead and pause the
video to see if you can solve them on
your own we'll go through them together
the first one it says what is the value
of D such that the system has no
solution ok so when you look at these
two equations here you know what does
this D value have to be so that there's
no solution so go ahead and pause the
video see if you can do it on your own
we'll go through it together ok so let's
take a look so we talked about the
elimination here in this example let's
take a look at elimination for this one
as well what would we have to do - let's
just say eliminate the Y values here
well what we could do is we can multiply
the second equation by negative 2 that
would give us negative 10 X - 6 y equals
negative 24 right so now when we add
these together the first and third like
this we're going to get D minus 10x the
6y negative 6y are going to cancel and
we get 8 plus negative 24 which is
negative
sixteen now in order for there to be no
solution we want not just the y-values
to cancel out but also the X variables
to cancel out as well so if D okay was
this is actually supposed to be DX here
but if D was 10 you're gonna get 10 X
minus 10 x equals negative 16 which is 0
equals negative 16 which doesn't make
any sense it's a nonsensical answer and
what that means is that these two lines
are parallel and that they don't
intersect they don't cross okay so
that's the idea here now another way to
approach this problem is you could
rewrite the equation in y equals MX plus
B form that's the slope-intercept form
and as long as the two equations have
the same slope but different
y-intercepts what that represents is
they're going up at the same angle okay
but they're crossing the y-axis at a
different point those two lines also
will not have a common point of
intersection because they're parallel so
a couple different ways one way is to
use the elimination method and if both
of the variables cancel out such that
you get two quantities that don't equal
one another then there's no solution now
if we would have gotten 0 equals 0 or
negative 16 equals negative 16 then what
that means is that they're the exact
same line okay one line is right on top
of the other line and they're actually
crossing at an infinite number of points
okay let's look at example number two
see if you can pause the video do this
one on your own we'll go through it
together
it says if your friend has already read
150 pages and reads 20 pages an hour and
you have just started the book and you
read 30 pages an hour how long will it
take you to catch up to your friend okay
so see if you can solve this system of
equations to find out how long it's
going to take for you to catch up to
your friend in this particular book that
you're both reading okay so first thing
we want to do is we want to write the
equation so let's just say that your
friend okay is reading 20 pages and on
let's see 20 pages an hour right so 20
times the number of hours plus they've
already read 150 pages and that's going
to be the total number of pages that
they've read now notice that this
equation is very similar to the
y equals MX plus B form of a line the M
is the slope or the rate okay and the B
is the y-intercept or the initial
condition the starting amount how many
pages he's already read or she's already
read right now the second equation is
relating to how many pages that you read
and you read 30 pages per hour so if
it's 2 hours you would have read 60
pages 3 hours 90 pages but your initial
condition your B value is zero because
you haven't started the book yet right
okay so this is our system right here we
want to solve the system I think the
easiest way to do this is just to do
this substitution method so if P equals
30 H let's go ahead and put 30 H in
place of P so that's 30 H equals 20 H
plus 150 subtract 28 from both sides
right because you want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other divide everything by 10 to solve
for one H and you can see it's going to
be 15 hours so in 15 hours maybe not all
in the same day but after 15 hours of
reading you're going to catch up to
where your friend is at in the book so
this is a very important concept
understanding systems of equations and
the SAT they emphasize it quite a bit
in many different forms where you might
have to write the equations yourself and
solve the system they may give you the
equations and you have to solve the
system you might have to find a value
where there's an infinite number of
solutions or no solution or you know it
might just be like a you know some kind
of variation of what we talked about
here so review the lesson if you need to
I'll see you in the next lesson